people want to know code and where we're
going next man where the travel shows
well we have a travel show that we shot
that is it is it's coming out and I
think it's a couple of weeks away and
basically I call [ __ ] I can say that
on the internet right sure sure
I call [ __ ] on Jordan shlonsky
Georgia Lansky's been acting like an
Italian man for years and so I actually
surprised him I put him on a plane I'd
take him to Italy and I make him I try
to expose him as a fraud to all the
people of Italy and it's really fun I
think it's gonna be a very funny travel
show and it has no social purpose this
one except calling him out as a guy
named shlonsky from Long Island so it
was we had a lot of adventures I'm sure
some of you followed along with that or
saw some of it out there but that show
is gonna have some very funny moments I
promise you the man's a freak and it was
it was it was great was really fun and
how do the Jordan thing first get
started a lot of people don't know the
origin outside from Jordan just being a
weirdo haunted it first
we noticed him around the office and
then back away night
yes back at late night and then there
was some strike shows where we had no
writers or anything so I think he took
me out in the hallway and showed me his
Harrison Ford whipped and he showed me
how to use it and crack it and then he
also showed me how to tango and he did
it with no irony no sense of like this
is funny and it was hilarious and then
Frank smiley one of our producers said
because Jordan talks all the time about
Italian food you got to take Jordan out
to an Italian meal and we'll shoot it
just the two of you and we did and it's
one of my favorite all-time you can look
it up I'm sure
Conan's Italian meal with Jordan where I
go I think I get pretty blasted what you
need to be to have dinner with George it
was it was I went into treatment shortly
after that meal and
it's for pasta not alpha and that got it
started and then I swear to God
everywhere I go in the world cars stop
people in traffic and people get out at
an intersection and say what's with
Jordan so that's my gift to America it's
the it's the craze that's sweeping the
nation wait have you met Jordan in
person
aside from anyone with her car one time
he floated into my space in San Diego
the bathroom and he was already there
and he goes you guys's voices
reverberate really nicely together
that's really that's a thing he said and
I have been thinking about it every day
every day someone said glad you brought
the cutout to Korea it's haunted Conan's
my that's nice glad you brought the
character Korea we brought a cutout of
shorten Oh Conan punch Aeryn every time
you mentioned Jordan well right now
listen there's controversy about this
because I know that there are people in
landed like don't be mean to Jordan to
to Aaron don't hurt him don't hurt him I
don't think I hurt you no you work out
sure all I do is hit you as hard as I
can and I'm six for about 195 pounds
yeah yeah you and you lift weights yeah
so I mentioned Jordan how many times you
think since I've been out here I want to
say a hundred and eighty two that's not
feel like this all right how about just
one good one actually no it actually it
doesn't hurt no it hurts sometimes it
hurts it for sure hurts I'll tell you
one time it actually really he kicked me
one time so we went bowling
we did a bowling thing with the Nerdist
people and you did push me down and kick
me that actually hurts I was I apologize
because you're not you're not she's not
good at kicking you're just you know you
had what punching you have control of
your body I didn't have full control and
I was doing it for comedic effect yes I
wasn't really trying to kick him but I
did you bowling shoes on and he kind of
slipped and it was it was it was a kick
and they were metal tipped bowling shoes
which I had requested they had a spike
on the tip but yeah that's know
otherwise it's only emotionally yeah oh
there's no no physical damage do you
want to hit god you guys talk you want
to hit Moses
I don't want to hit you see what about
he's a Joffrey but you know Sansa
Joffrey on the show Sansa his job
because he was a real jerk
yeah here's well director so really I
mean you did this would kind of you know
would really use the money from the
lawsuit already got that sweet sweet a
YouTube red cast member is like a piece
that's this baby would blow that's
really good
[Music]